[Music]
hello everyone so today at the keynote
you probably heard that we are unifying
the developer experience for instant
apps and Android app bundles and so my
colleague Ben and I are going to talk to
you a little bit about how that works
from the developer perspective so
instant apps it's a technology that we
introduced a little over two years ago
at Google i/o and it lets you give you
users and native Android app experience
without them having to explicitly go and
install your app from the Play Store now
how that works is you split up your app
into smaller pieces called features and
the user can reach those via a link a
URL and also via other means as we'll
see later in this presentation now to
get your app small enough and to be able
to launch it instantly instant apps for
the first time used a technology that we
introduced in Android 5 lollipop
that's called split apks now with
configuration split apks Play Store was
able to deliver the smallest most
optimized version of your app to a
user's device now in order to do that
the build system that the Gradle Android
build system that you have and you build
your apps with build all of those split
apks locally bundled them in a zip file
called an instant bundle and then you
upload that to the Play Store so the
Play Store can choose from the set of
apks and delivered them to devices now
to do that the developer had to do some
significant refactoring in your apps so
the project structure of an instant app
as it looked - one year ago look
probably something like this first of
all you had to take all of your base
application code and move it from the
application module to a base feature
then you had to split your app into
future modules containing the various
features in your app or normally we
would call them screens or activities
and then you had these two almost empty
dummy modules application and instant
app for building the artifact
that we need so the apk for application
that would be the installed application
and he used to have and then the instant
app is a bundle that would contain all
the split apks that you upload to a
separate track in the Play Store now
this was not ideal as I said it required
significant work from you your project
no longer look simple same time this
year we introduced a new publishing
format for Android apps called the
Android app bundle or AAA B now this
format preserves some more information
about what's happening in your project
it contains some metadata about
targeting of the resources native
libraries and so on there are in your
project but it also actually retains
some of the module information about a
new type of module called dynamic
feature that's in your project now I
called it a publishing format because
you use it to upload this whole big
bundle telling the Play Store everything
about your app to play and then together
with Google Play dynamic delivery we are
able to serve an optimized set of split
apks to users devices now in order to do
that there's one big difference because
it happens on a cert on the server side
on the Play Store we need to be able to
resize your app that's why if you use an
Android app bundle you have to enable
app signing by Google Play now that's a
good thing actually if you let us store
your key for you it is safer it's more
secure but there's also another benefit
thanks to the fact that we can transform
your apks and make them more optimized
as we develop more optimizations on the
Play Store side over time what we
deliver to users devices can be even
more optimized as we just announced with
uncompressed libraries and so it will
make sense to move instant apps to this
new model why build all the apks locally
and then not be able to optimize them
further on the Play Store what if we
could use the new app bundle format to
deliver an instant app experience to our
users so let me tell you how to go back
to that simpler better project structure
for your instant apps so if you if
you've ever done that whole dance to
move modules around and move your code
to a base feature and so on we literally
have to go back to that
simple project to use as you would build
your apk so first of all we no longer
need the instant app plug-in everything
that we need is baked into the
application plugin that can now build
bundles and so we don't need the base
feature anymore instead we can move our
code back to the application or we will
be using that to build our unified
bundle artifact and so again with future
modules we now replace them with dynamic
features that work within the app bundle
world so ultimately we want something
simple you can have your application
application module with any additional
library modules that you need optionally
we have dynamic features that can be
downloaded on demand adding
functionality to your app at runtime and
we have the single piece of metadata
that tells the Play Store that this
bundle is instant app enabled so that
would be great if you could upload that
one artifact to the Play Store and have
it published both on the install an
instant track and that's exactly what we
were what we were aiming for now there's
one caveat we are currently testing that
with our partners but you might not
actually be able to upload this single
artifact to the Play Store just yet
that's why if you want to try it right
now
I suggest you create two product
variants in there in this simple project
structure still and in one of the
variants simply enable their metadata
with enabling the instant app for your
bundle and use the other variant to
build a bundle without that entry in the
manifest it's still simple enough so one
project one app one code base just for
the time being you might have to do that
in order to order to upload to the Play
Store by the way there's another
whitelist if you want to use dynamic
features in order to let your users
download them on demand as they run your
app this is also under a whitelist for
developers who want to test that you can
apply online however you are currently
not able to publish your app to the
production track if you have more than
one module ok so how to try it yourself
right now first thing you need to do is
use the new Android studio 3.3 that's
currently on the beta Channel and if
you're creating a project from scratch
you can simply
this checkbox will create the modules
with the necessary metadata already in
there so that's how it looks like in
your base manifest you instant enable it
and you're good to go if your app if
your app is compliant with all the other
instant app restrictions such as file
size which Ben we'll talk about later
now you have a chance to publish an
instant enabled bundle already now if
you already have a project which you're
using to build an app bundle you can
also use the new module wizard to add a
new instant dynamic feature module this
will also if you add one of these this
will also instant enable your base
module if you haven't done so now all
that's left is design a bundle build an
app bundle ID or through Gradle so the
bundle release command instead of a
symbol release or through the wizard and
the UI by the way if you're using our
Android dev summit app right here at
this conference it's been built exactly
as an instant enable app bundle
so we publish that to our through our
channels on the Play Store that what
you're using right now is exactly what
I'm talking about and it's been great
it's greatly simplified what we had to
do in order to have that working now let
me invite on stage Ben who will tell you
a little bit about best practices for
modularizing
and discover you of your app then thank
our applause please thank you very much
so yeah let me talk a bit about
discoverability of your instant apps
basically one of them you already saw
which is to try now functionality I'll
talk a little bit more about this
so try now basically is the second
button that you get on the Play Store
which allows your users to inside on
load and run the app straight from the
Play Store without having to permanently
install it on device that's a great
experience that you can easily see how
it worked you can go to the Play Store
now and check it out for the Android dev
summit app and your users can launch it
directly from the landing page it's
quite cool and if you don't have a URL
associated with your app that works as
well so you don't have the restrictions
that Europe has mapped to URLs anymore
how do you do that
that's basically it I think that
everybody has this somewhere in their
application it's the main launcher and
if you don't have you don't have to do
anything else then at the instant meter
data that you're already attic showed
you earlier so there's nothing else that
you have to do in order to be eligible
for it try now experience but what if
your app if you want to have your app
available with a URL mapping that allows
you basically to access your app through
any URL that you have associated with
your app the first thing you have to do
is you have to verify that you own the
domain that you do that you generate and
upload an asset links JSON file there's
a couple of helpers online that verify
whether it is all you uploaded is
correct and the one that you have in
your app the mapping is correct with
that as well
and then you can share the link with
anyone and they can open the app
straight away let me walk you through
how that works from where we started
with the main launcher basically you
have to set a second intent filter with
you auto verify flag set to true that
flag tells the Play Store that it should
check for the asset links Jason foil on
the URL provided below then you add the
action view category browser will
default that you say that this is the
one thing that I want to use as the
default to view this URL you don't add
the scheme's for HTTP HTTPS and you can
add multiple paths or path prefixes to
just walk through user through to
multiple of your activities for the one
that you want to use as the default
activity so when they come from try now
or whether they come from your home
screen is the metadata here that has to
be a sibling tag to do you above instant
filter which just says this is a default
URL and this is where I want my users to
come in initially like I said earlier if
you don't have a URL in the first place
you don't have to do this but if you
have to have a URL mapping then this is
the way to go and it's not a lot of work
to do and it gives you the users the
experience that you can share any link
that leads to your app and any Android
user can then open the app straight away
without having to install it permanently
and I think for a conference is a good
use case to have an app that you use
once and you don't have to fully install
it
you have the instant app and for a
couple of features like in our case it's
notifications you still have to install
the app but it's fair enough to have an
experience that you can start
straightaway without the first steps
necessary also there's another thing
that we use for app bundles in order to
download code dynamically so going back
to the the previous section is basically
you can do that with the zip and feature
in synapse what we're going on forward
now you have to ship your app as an app
bundle and you have to use dynamic
feature modules in order to make use of
the play core library the play core
library allows you to download features
dynamically on demand so not during the
initial installation and it's unified
between instant app and installed app so
you don't have to do different calls on
that and it does all the heavy lifting
so if you say to play query a library
download this it connects to the Play
Store it downloads it it puts it in the
right place for instant apps it puts it
into the share cache there and for an
installed app and insulted on device
permanently so how does it work well you
add it as a dependency available from
maven Google come and use it in your in
your project and then you create a split
install manager factory within your
activity hold on to that create a
request where you can install one or
multiple modules at the same time those
module names have to match the module
name that you set for the dynamic
feature module directly in the manifest
of that module you build it and then you
just tell the manager to start the
installation and that's all the coding
you eat in order to get started with it
obviously there's a couple of things
that you have to do around it I'll go
into that in a second but before we do
that if you don't want to start the
installation straightaway there's a way
to do a deferred installation so for
example if you have your instant app you
started you and you know that your user
is in a flow where they're where they're
for example buying something so they've
logged in and then they're starting the
purchase process and you want to have
and you want to download a payment
payment module for example you can do
that deferred or during the flow when
when the users in that you can do
installations also uninstallation its
deferred at some point so that means the
uninstallation doesn't get done straight
away but at some point where the system
says yes I'm cleaning up and this is
where this is module get all right it
also gets removed and you can also
cancel installation requests for if for
whatever reason you from the from the
developer perspective want to cancel
that there's an option to do it and
there's a listener you can set on the
under manager that's my preferred way of
listening for the state updates the
split install state update listener it's
quite a word and there's quite a few
things so usually what happens the happy
path is you trigger and install your app
starts with pending and then goes to
downloading downloaded and then there is
installing and installed that's your
happy path that's what happens for an
app that is or for a module that is
small enough to not trigger the requires
user confirmation if you go into that
state you will get be given a couple of
some information that you can start an
intent with and that intent allows you
to show a dialog that the user can
confirm or deny whether they want to
install this module at this point if
they confirm that you want to install
you come back into the happy path and
continue downloading an installation at
most points that your installation can
be canceled or in a canceling state as
well as for a couple of reasons it can
fail so that's the path where you have
to handle all those states we do have a
sample available for that and I'll share
a URL that later on in the session so
you can take a look at how it works like
I talked a little bit file size limit
that triggers for example the requires
user confirmation coincides with a
couple of limits that we have set for
instant apps in general and for for
dynamic delivery one of the things we do
is we don't take the installed size
already downloaded size as the main
factor anymore so if your app on device
has a file size that it's larger than a
limit then that's alright because we
could take the download size into
account so you get some compression over
the wire and that's what we take into
account for that
and this will be shown on the play and
the play console as well so you'll see
your download size as this so your above
or below the threshold also dynamic
feature modules don't fall into the
initial download size as well what falls
into it is basically your base module
and your instant entry module if you
have more than one which you can have
then it's your base module and your
largest instant entry module and those
currently under a whitelist
have to be less than 10 megabytes
dynamic feature modules that you
download later on or other instant entry
modules that are smaller don't fall into
these ten megabytes in the first place
but let me tell you a little bit about
what these entails so if your app is
larger than ten megabytes well you don't
get any of the instant have benefits
you can't yup can't be with this couple
or real discoverable two users as an
instant app if your app is less than ten
but more than four megabytes your app
can be seen as an instant app and can be
used as an intern app so you can can
show it you can access it through try
now on the Play Store and also you can
show it in web banners or share it via
URLs if your app or your app your base
module and your instant entry module is
less than four megabytes then your app
can be discovered from everywhere that
means from ads from search results so
for example if you search for the
Android dev summit app you will see a
search result if you click that you will
go straight to the instant app on your
Android device that's because it's under
this four megabytes threshold and while
you're at it you can continue
modularizing I know motorizing is a
tricky topic because it entails some
work that some people are not 100%
certain how that is done best we
recently went through the whole process
with a project it's called plaid it's
online available it's available in
github and I'll talk a little bit about
how we managed to move away from a
monolithic app to an app that uses app
bundles and dynamic feature modules
while it's not currently an instant map
it usually a unified approach uses the
same technology underneath that you can
use for modularizing an instant app as
well so firstly what we did is we know
the most apps will do is we created a
base module where
hosts all the domain code and data so
shared access to share preferences
login for example some repositories some
persistent API calls and things like
that and on top of that are different
feature modules those future modules
have their own domain code their own
logic and obviously the UI which is only
displayed in this module and that setup
can be used for many apps if you have a
base module which shares information and
on top of that the different future
modules but let me share a little bit on
more in-depth what we did so initially
we had an app which is the module that
most people have so we had this monolith
and if we ship as an apk that's fine
because well there is no reason to go
into the whole modernization part part
if we in in the end have one single
monolithic app apk de we ship to our
users but since we were considering
going towards dynamic feature modules
and app bundles we moved everything into
your base which on the one hand had the
shared dependencies which basically
means everything that we include coming
from whatever repositories externally as
well as a couple of local first party a
third party api's and libraries that we
have forked and worked with we after we
had this we started working on features
that we extracted from the from the app
itself the first we started with was an
about screen because well and about your
screen it's kind of untangled from most
of the stuff that we have within the app
so it's a good starting point for
getting our hands with wet with how do
you e yeah with what does it actually
entail to make a dynamic feature module
how do we do all those things
then we went on to do a search screen
and after that we have two newest host
two new sources that we extracted into
dynamic future modules as well and they
all depend on the app and that the app
and everything shares the information
through that as well you can read up
more in depth on a blog post on the
Android developers medium block
publication and also we do have
information available on inside apps in
general and on app bundle as well as
samples on Android dynamic features as
well as how to use internet without URLs
the Android intern app team is
outside at the office hours to share
information and knowledge if you have
questions please come over there and
with that thank you very much
[Music]